this is 26 year old Daria tripova being
questioned by Russian authorities in
Saint Petersburg
I brought a statue there that blew up
she says who gave you the statue they
asked
can I tell you later she replies the bus
was handed to prominent military blogger
gladlyn tartarsky it exploded killing
him and injuring dozens of people on
Sunday evening tirpova has yet to
provide a name and says she's been
framed the attack happened at a cafe in
the heart of Saint Petersburg the
National anti-terror Committee which is
part of the Russian Security Service
says it was planned by the Ukrainian
special services
a charge authorities in Kiev have denied
we expect that now Russia also will know
the response but everyone would ask
how many
people will be killed by keep regime are
here in Moscow before Russia will
respond
nobody knows exactly but probably
more time coming
more strong will be a response
was speaking at an event organized by
The cyberfund Zed movement an
association of people with patriotic
views
he was a supporter of Russia's Invasion
and the social media channel he launched
a report on the so-called special
military operation had more than half a
million subscribers
KY was a well-known figure among Kremlin
supporters
seen here with Daria dugina who was
killed in a car bomb attack in the
Moscow region in August
her father Alexander Dugan a far-right
political philosopher was believed to be
the intended target
the Kremlin says tartarsky's killing is
an act of Terror and that evidence
implicates Ukrainian special services
without providing any further details
while these types of attacks are rare in
Russia the planning and plotting behind
them suggests that the battles are no
longer confined to the donbass region
dorsuchabari Al Jazeera Moscow